في تطورات التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه اعتدى مستوطنون على اراضي
الفلسطينيين الواقعه قرب مستوطنه عتيل
المقامه على اراضي فلسطينيين في قريه كرمه
جنوب الخليل وقال مراسل الجزيره ان اليات
الحفر تعمل في ساعات الليل على شق طريق
استيطاني بمحاذاه المستوطنه تمهيدا لل
سلاء على ما يقرب من الف دنم من اراضي
المواطنين الفلسطينيين
وضمها ل مستوطنه
عتنا كما اعتد مستوطنون بحمايه من قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على مواطنين
فلسطينيين في خربه سوسيا بمسافر يطا جنوبي
الخليل كما اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الطفله
سليمان الكعابنه من قريه دقيقه بمسافر في
اليطه اثناء رعيه للاغنام ونقلته الى جهه
مجهوله هذا وبثت منصات محليه فلسطينيه
مشاهد لحريق في قريه ظهر العبد قرب بلده
يعبد جنوبي مدينه جينين بالضفه الغربيه
المحتله وبحسب مصادر فلسطينيه فان
مستوطنين هم من اشعل النيران في المنطقه
بحمايه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لمتابعه التطورات في الضفه
الغربيه انضم الينا من رام الله مراسل
الجزيره محمد خيري اهلا بك معنا نتابع معك
اخر التطورات فيما يتعلق
بتحركات المستوطنين في الايام
الاخيره نعم عبد السلام اعتداءات
المستوطنين الاسرائيليين على المواطنين
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه اخذه
بالتوسع والازدياد منذ السابع من اكتوبر
وحتى هذا اليوم بشكل شبه يومي هذه
الاعتداءات شملت خلال الفترات الماضيه
عمليات دهم للمنازل واعتداء على الاراضي
وتكسير و تيم اشجار الزيتون وكذلك وصلت في
بعض الحالات الى قتل مواطنين
فلسطينيين اليوم اعتدت مجموعه من
المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين على غرف زراعيه تابعه لمواطن
فلسطيني قرب قريه يعبد في شمالي الضفه
الغربيه احرق المستوطنون الاسرائيليون هذه
الغرف الزراعيه بكل ما فيها من ممتلكات
تابعه للمواطنين الفلسطينيين
وايات يستخدمونها للزراعه
وفلاحه الارض كل ذلك تم دون اي رادع يتعرض
له المستوطنون الاسرائيليون من قبل قوات
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ودون ان يحصل
المواطن الفلسطيني على حقه في الحمايه من
هذه الاعتداءات كما ايضا اعتدت مجموعه من
المستوطنين على اراضي مواطنين فلسطينيين
في قريه كرما في مدينه الخليل ايضا وهناك
داهمت هذه المجموعات اراض تابعه
للفلسطينيين هذه الاراضي ايضا تقوم قوات
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ليلا بحفرها وشق
شوارع فيها من اجل شق شارع استيطاني على
حساب اراضي المواطنين الفلسطينيين كما
افادنا اصحاب
تلك الاراضي تعرضت هذه الارض وكذلك
المواطنين هناك الاعتداءات من قبل المواطن
المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين كما ايضا اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عده مدن وقرى ومخيمات
في الضفه الغربيه هذه الليله كما تفعل في
كل ليله منذ السابع من اكتوبر وحتى هذا
اليوم في الضفه الغربيه فاقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال مدينه اريحا شرقي الضفه الغربيه
وخاصه مخيمي عين السلطان وعقبه جبر وهناك
سياره الياتها العسكريه في شوارع المخيمات
و شرت قوات ايضا راجله في الشوارع وحصرت
عددا من البنايات السكنيه وداهمت عددا من
منازل المواطنين الفلسطينيين كما ايضا
اقتحمت قوات عسكريه اسرائيليه قبل قليل
قريه النصاريه في مدينه نابلس شمالي الضفه
الغربيه ايضا وكذلك كفر قدوم في مدينه
قلقيليه حيث سيرت قوات الاحتلال الياتها
وكذلك قواتها الراجله في احياء هذه القريه
وكذلك حاصرت ايضا هناك عمارات سكنيه ودهمت
منازل مواطنين فلسطينيين تقول قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انها تبحث عن من
تسميهم المطلوبين للاجهزه الاسرائيليه في
مدن الضفه الغربيه واندلعت ايضا مواجهات
قبل عده ساعات في قريه قفين في مدينه طول
كرم شمالي الضفه الغربيه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اقتحمت هذه القريه من محا عده
وسيرت الياتها كذلك هناك اندلعت مواجهات
مع مواطنين فلسطينيين واطلقت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيل النار الحيه باتجاه
المواطنين ما ادى الى اصابه احد المواطنين
اخيرا عبد السلام دعني اقول ان عدد حالات
الاعتقال في الضفه الغربيه المستمره بلغت
اكثر من 6500 حاله اعتقال في الضفه
الغربيه ومدينه القدس خلال ما يقل عن
اربعه اشهر محمد خيري مراسل الجزيره من
رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك